you know people are complaining about
Matt wall saying he's too mean and I
don't even think he was that mean and uh
seeing like Alex Stein he I Alex Stein's
like a one-up on Matt Walsh I mean you
could say Matt Walsh is direct but Alex
Stein like really grinds people's gears
like he he goes in front of the
protesters there are people who hate him
yeah oh yeah I love when he goes in
front of the protesters and he's like hi
so here's what he does here's the
technique
right the important component that
people need to understand about what
Alex Stein does is that he doesn't
insult them he laughs says I love you
and he's too tall for them to block so
he holds the camera up and then he just
starts saying I love you you guys and
he's smiling and it drives them insane
it is one of the most brilliant tactics
so if y'all are concerned about Matt
Walsh we got out Alex Stein right here
but let's be real Alex Stein pisses
people off way more than Matt Walsh does
his tactic is more infuriating because
it's hard to counter it he's just having
a great time